i started listening to this podcast i
should bring him a shout out
on uh september 11th [ __ ]
and you might be right there's some
shady [ __ ] with that i didn't look into
it enough
tower seven so it's called theories of
the third kind
and it's their uh episode number 65
911. you know who you got you know who
who's really uh
in tune with that sam trampoline besides
sam white mike
white mike white mike is pretty white
mike you got to listen to him on it too
uh he's solid yeah it's got threes of a
third kind podcasts fantastic it's three
three people and i think one dude was in
the waco texas cult way called testing
so do you see what is that one's
did you watch the netflix one of course
oh no i want to piss you off i did i did
the way the government handled that they
really [ __ ] them the media [ __ ] up
exactly the media is super [ __ ] man
so i was doing this hurting
abuse of the kids it wasn't even they
came in there and uh they
they did like investigation like no he
didn't touch anything at all but
they didn't want to hear that waco texas
waco texas i don't know about this
oh that's like uh from the 90s yes like
93 97 maybe yeah but back to september
11th dog
it is mind blowing when you start
hearing the details you're like
what i'm trying to tell you so you know
the security
of the tower of the 911 towers like the
twin towers
the security yeah go ahead you know it's
bush's
cousin who runs security well he said it
like that
right you know that business did you
know when the first plane
ran into the building the first one the
other the south tower
they got on the intercom like stay calm
it's not a big deal just stay there
don't worry about it
yeah they told them to stay in that
building why then did you know that
some of the floors on that building were
cleared out ahead of time
before that day like just some of the
floors were dead empty some people
didn't go to work that day exactly when
they told
exactly oh they don't know this floors
were empty
did you know that um remember president
uh
bush was the president when 9 11
happened george bush uh junior
when uh he was doing like a thing at a
elementary school
and when they went and told him they're
like it doesn't make sense because they
tell him he's not like oh
[ __ ] they tell him and any other time
they're like yo
so they're flying these planes into
buildings dog
you've announced you're here if they're
going like you're the main target
we should get the [ __ ] out of it
remember he just chilled there didn't
rush out or nothing just chilled there
when you start like into it and i'm not
a big conspiracy looking into it all
this [ __ ] you're like
yeah it's mind-boggling yeah you just
got and then did you know because you
know
uh george uh junior i think that george
bush george bush junior george w bush
you know he
you know he was the head of the cia
before he was president
and before that he owned like a
construction company
you know his main business in texas
right you know
his main business was a business
uh uh osama bin laden's family paid him
a ton of money
so when when all this happened and there
was like a big like
uproaring like uh wait george was senior
george was senior
got it no george george w bush was ctia
oh i thought you said no he was head of
c.i.a
oh god okay before he was president but
a lot of his uh
business was with the bin ladens
yeah and now he's doing art and [ __ ] i
don't know what the [ __ ] he's doing
it's it's great what yeah you think
about that guys
and then so america is known for having
the best air force like
in the world by far not even close yeah
and they could have
easily taken out those planes and there
was warnings before but no one
supposedly took him serious
so they could have easily taken out like
like a date like days before there was
morning there all those warnings leading
up to
a ton of points they just ignored them i
remember watching that [ __ ] on tv when i
was me too
i was a freshman in college my dad i
call my um i call my dad and he's like
he's like can you believe this i'm like
what he's like god damn it turn on a
[ __ ] tv
i turn on like he's all aggressive and
then also the way
uh they said that uh they had like these
engineers talking about
what the way the planes hit the
buildings like yeah they collapsed due
to the
the fuel the the fuel from the jet fuel
jet fuel don't work like that because
like when they were digging up like when
the towers fell and the way they fell
yeah they were digging through trying to
find [ __ ] you know there was like
lava like it was melted jet fuel don't
do that
jet field don't do that jeffy don't do
that so what does that
they have the theories and what does it
and the way they fell the way they fell
is just like
when they demolish buildings yeah and
that's the way they notice how they
didn't go like this
yeah like that they came down they came
down set up okay and then and then you
know the plane i think was flight 93
so so flight knife through that r uh
that i ran into the pentagon you know
what time yeah
yeah yeah that's like they ran into the
pedro what's interesting about that is
the pentagon
they had a guy who works for the
pentagon talk about this they have a
system there where they think it's close
they have these missiles that shoot it
the [ __ ] down so
they uh dick cheney was the vice
president you know dick cheney when they
told him hey
uh they hijacked the plane he goes shoot
it down yeah they want to shoot it down
because they thought they're gonna run
another building you'll shoot it down
so they they say that so they could have
saw that you're saying they could have
saw that plane coming
they could have this oh yeah but but
here but here's what because you know
they stopped all air travel
so any planes in the air were hijacked
so when that plane
ran into the pentagon a lot of people
who are on the outside like that live
around the area
said they saw a rocket hit the plane and
now right before it got there it hit it
and then it crashed
here's what's interesting though all the
[ __ ] like
the all the documentation of al qaeda
bin laden george bush construction
business all that
where that plane hit what do you think
it hit it hit all those documents
all those documents are gone now so the
area that that plane ran into
is where they keep all their documents
and so just they're exposed exactly so
they don't have any traces back to the
corruption
damn that's crazy so yeah i'm not being
conspiracy guy but there's
so many con coincidences i'm like dude
yeah it's like the jfk
yeah or jfk i know for a fact is
yeah we know for a fact that is not a
didn't they say bush senior had
something to do with that
or no not no it was uh who uh hoover
oh yeah but yeah no just digging into it
yeah unless this podcast like what you
should also listen to this like i'm
still
like deep diving in the federal reserve
act but that that one that same podcast
goes in so they they own it all
conspiracy so they went to jfk
and then they go to their theirs was
mafia a lot of people go into the
the the cuba ties which i don't really
[ __ ] with but
um they go deep into how the mafia
basically set up jfk
well-documented for sure the mafia me
but then also they go into
uh oh at pizzagate
pizzagate pizzagate how
it you know we talked about this oh yeah
i talked to the owner dude i didn't know
the owner was a [ __ ]
creep like homebrew oh no super creepy
super creepy what do you mean explain
well
where do i begin it's like hit just his
the coincidences of you know so the
reason all this got out was
through uh wikipedia leaks where they
got this
uh government official's email list and
his whole email list had all these key
phrases like
like uh like hidden terms about pizza
that's why you call it pizzagate so they
say hey i need a cheese piece of
pepperoni
yeah well that in the pet pedophile ring
is like the way you describe kids
so i need pizza with sausage little boys
i need pizza cheese only little girls
whatever they have all these hidden
terms
and when you get deep into it like holy
[ __ ] dude
it's not so that's so that's gonna make
you sick i have to turn the
pizzagate one off if you have kids you
don't wanna listen to hell no yeah so
that's why i wasn't
on the flight i was like his [ __ ] is so
dark oh damn that's why you're so groggy
on it
then i went to the wait the waco one
will just if you look more into waco it
will drive you
[ __ ] it's so [ __ ] up the way the
fbi and the government dealt with that
it was
so [ __ ] up so basically he had this uh
compound right he had this compound he
had a family there yeah and people
you know families moving they had
lawyers that you would quit their jobs
to become part of his quote unquote cult
he had like all this stuff going on they
had a lot of arms like that a lot of
guns and [ __ ]
and someone someone like snitched on him
to like
you know like uh at a bar like hey this
dude's hurting kids and stuff like that
so the media picked up on it
and the media made this whole like big
deal about it no like the
like the texas government would give a
[ __ ] and the guy's doing his thing on
his land they don't get [ __ ]
and then as far as him having a cult
yeah they don't care
and so they're like oh he has guns there
there's illegal guns there and he's
he's hitting kids none of that was true
no
so then he starts getting you know
investigated
and then that's when the the cut they're
like hey we have a warrant we're gonna
check out the house
and uh they had dogs on the property
this is what they think they had dogs on
the property
so when these atf agents came on the
property there's dogs for protection
the docks started barking the atf agents
shot the dogs pissed them off
the people in the house thought they
were shooting at them so they start
firing
so they start firing back they kill some
fbi atf agents
well they don't [ __ ] with that and i
talk about egos with the government they
start firing back
then they're like come out and then all
the the waco
people are like dude this this we're not
coming out you guys are [ __ ] with us
for no reason
we never hit kids they did an
investigation they never touched kids
the kids were treated great there
and then also the media played the
narrative oh they live with no power no
water no food
yeah because you got to shut off the
power like you guys shut off the power
that's why he was like dad we don't live
like that we have a great setup here
so what did netflix didn't cover that
but netflix they did but it was like a
more watered down they did because the
way they
and here's the thing so finally they're
like all right you can go
let's get rid of these people go in
there and get rid of them because they
were they weren't they weren't doing
[ __ ]
right so they'd go in there and get rid
of them because it came in the ego thing
because they shot
public officials yeah yeah yeah one
percent so i go in there give them so
they release this gas
that's supposed to be harmful like not
harm it's supposed to be harmful to the
compound
bro listen to this they drive a [ __ ]
military tank yeah
into into the house release the gas well
where they hit the
the brick wall where all the kids and
women were
so the wall falls crushes like 10 of the
kids crushed their skulls kills them
instantly
then the gas they pumped a thing it was
so much gas
the concentration was so high all the
women children died
so they killed like 27 kids and then
those atf agents the fbi agents
there's pictures of them with the ashes
of the bodies celebrating
and the kids because so they the fbi was
like the negotiators like hey let the
kids go and we'll give you water and
melt for the babies because they you
know that's
they need uh energy and fuel so they're
like all right we're gonna let some kids
go that makes no sense the kids don't
want to leave
they taught kids and leaving like don't
worry we're all gonna get out here soon
don't worry
so the fbi would take these kids and
house them in a uh
government housing but they'd be there
on fbi agents and fbi agents
with all their stuff tore through all
their stuff cut up their teddy bears
talk
[ __ ] to them all the time and then when
they raided the house they said hey
everyone has to gather around turn on
the tv was like watch this
and that's when they like they lost all
their family it's [ __ ] up
did you know in 1913 fbi was formed and
created
same year as the irs
the irs coming after you no no you're
not paying taxes
don't don't no again i'm paying that
student loan no i'm just saying because
he was talking about that
with thomas brother i'm just saying the
fbi was formed in 1913 did you know that
did you know why they were formed
because we can go into it because i'm
i'm on it i'm on this research i'm on
this journey
listen that pocket so they do the
research oh and then they actually get
into that uh
vegas shooter that's it we was talking
about that this weekend though
okay but i don't want to bring up oh the
malaysian
plane i'm not a big conspiracy guy
anyone
he said you keep saying that you keep
saying
this week they're like an hour long you
go through all of them that
especially on that flight that 9 11 when
i was like [ __ ]
dude and then they have there's a lot of
people calling in to their family or
they have the flight attendant [ __ ] yeah
she calls down
she's like they're like yes go ahead
whatever 997. shell hey
the plane's been hijacked and he's like
what she explains been hijacked two
people in the pilot were stabbed in the
front
it's like what the [ __ ] and these
[ __ ] idiots the al-qaeda
uh yeah al-qaeda who took over the plane
you know they
they were trained in america trained in
florida actually how to fly planes
but they these were new planes so they
turned on a thing and they thought they
were talking to the plane
and on the plane you know they thought
they were telling everyone hey just stay
calm
don't be a hero everyone you'll be fine
but they were talking to air control
that's how air control found out they
hijacked the planes
it's nuts and then you hear these muslim
guys say a prayer
and then they've crashed playing to the
ground that's how they normally do they
they scream this is crazy dog
that 911 [ __ ] the way it fell the jet
fuel
the the ties to the the bushes it's
nuts and and osama it's not stupid so
are you on the fence now are you on
because earlier you was like yo yeah i
know it just sounded more fun to just go
with it but now no there's too many
there's too many too many ties to it
knowledge is power man you gotta
you know be nice if we gonna hit us with
another quote
but then these these these people in the
podcast do a great job with the research
they go is it very detailed like they go
well they go
you know it's only an hour i'm sure they
could do four hours but
for the hour they go into like the meat
and potatoes what you need to know yeah
and then they don't dive too much in
where they found or why
but then when they talk about like
what's a reason why you'd go to like you
need to give
americans a reason to support the war in
the middle east yeah well
flying killing three thousand americans
at the twin towers is a good reason it's
good
i think it's true a lot a lot happened
in 2001
man it's crazy it's crazy yeah do you
believe in that [ __ ]
yeah i mean some of the conspiracies now
i'm around sam all the time
right he's super balls deep in it yeah
and then brian's also like
no sam's like yes so i see you somewhere
in the middle where i'm like i'm in the
middle
i'm in the middle oh you're more in the
middle yeah when you look into it you're
just like god come on
look into it to make coincidence but
yeah all you gotta do is look into it
but some of those conspiracy theories
some are like flat earth get the [ __ ]
out of my face
i'm talking about flattery i love what
he does how about that
when i get off stage at the lap factory
right away you go bro
i figure out what you look like i'm like
what just run a bunch of other comics
i'm like what you're like
you look like a rottweiler you got a
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son